-Dwayne Johnson,
it is an honor to work with you.
My name is Ron.
I'm the director.
-Hi, Ron. Good to meet you.
-We're just gonna do
a couple targeted promos
for your new movie,
"Black Adam,"
you know,
really get the word out.
-Alright, sounds great.
Let's do it.
-Let's do this. Here we go.
-Okay.
This first one is for
the New York market, okay?
-Got it.
-Just read the teleprompter.
And...action.
-Hey, New York.
Dwayne Johnson here, telling you
all to go see "Black Adam"
in theaters and IMAX
October 21st.
-That was great. That was great.
-Thank you.
Can we do one more?
-What?
-Can we do one more?
Maybe like a -- Maybe do, like,
a New York-y accent, you know?
Maybe like -- like, "New York."
Why don't you that.
Why don't you try that.
-Okay.
[ New York accent ]
Hey, hey, hey, New York.
It's Dwayne Johnson over here.
Go see "Black Adam," alright?
What? Are you kidding me?
It's out October 21st,
and don't fugghetaboutit."
-That was it. That's perfect.
Absolutely perfect.
Alright, it's great.
-That okay?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-Next up is Texas.
And just read the prompter.
-Texas. I love Texas. Alright.
Hey, Texas.
This is Dwayne Johnson.
Go see my new movie,
"Black Adam,"
in theaters and IMAX
on October 21st.
-Nailed it, nailed it.
Can we do another one here?
Just maybe do a,
like, a drawl this time.
You know, maybe do like
a little --
like, get a
little cowboy in there.
-Like a -- What do you mean?
Like --
-Well, a cowboy in there.
Get just a little...
You know what?
You know, maybe just put --
maybe put this hat on here,
and that will put you
in the mood.
And there --
That'll be perfect, yeah.
This will be good.
-Okay.
-Yeah, perfect.
Just try that. Yeah.
-Alright.
-And just -- Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Country music playing ]
-[ Texas accent ] Howdy, Texas.
Y'all go see "Black Adam,"
now, you hear me?
And tell 'em
Dwayne Johnson sent ya.
-Yeah, yeah.
Love it, love it, love it.
It was good. It's okay.
-I don't know.
I mean, do you mind just putting
this giant belt buckle on?
Just hold it around your waist.
-Wait.
Are you sure?
-Oh, trust me.
I mean, are you kidding me?
Yeah, this --
Just put it around your waist
and maybe kick your feet out,
like just do this
while you're doing it.
-I don't know about that.
-No, trust me.
You want people in Texas
to see "Black Adam"?
-No, I do.
-Well, there you go, then.
We're rolling, we're rolling.
[ Country music playing ]
-[ Texas accent ]
Yee-haw partner.
Go see "Black Adam."
I hear everything's
bigger in Texas.
Now, go see it in IMAX."
-That's perfect. That is great.
That is great. That is great.
-I don't know about that, man.
-No, that is perfect.
That's awesome.
Next up, we have San Diego.
Let's bring in the props.
That's perfect.
-Props?
What are you talking about?
-Yeah, this will be great.
This is...
-Wait a sec. No, wait. Hold on.
-No, this is good.
-I don't know.
Is this necessary?
-Trust me, trust me.
Will you just trust me?
I'm Ron, the director.
When people see this
in San Diego,
those movie numbers are gonna go
up and through the roof.
People will be naming
their kids Dwayne Johnson.
-Okay.
-Just look --
-I don't know about this, man.
This seems like what --
-Just read the prompter.
This is only gonna play
in San Diego.
No one's ever going to see it.
-Okay.
-'Sup, brahs?
After a long day of shredding
some gnarly waves-age,
go see -- Are you sure?
-Yeah, yeah, that's perfect.
-Alright.
-Go see "Black Adam"
at your local theater, dude.
Peace out, bro-homey.
-Yeah, that's right.
That's it right there.
-I don't know, man.
-Mind equals blown.
[ Laughs ]
That's really great.
Can we just get in
the other props here?
That was perfect.
You nailed that one.
-I don't know. Wait.
-Let's get this.
No, this is gonna be good here.
This one's for for YouTube Kids.
Okay?
Just put that on there,
and then --
Yeah, just put on the hat.
Yeah, this is gonna be great.
And if you can --
If you can get low,
if you get low as you can --
-Get low?
-Yeah, get as low as you can.
That'd be really perfect.
Just see how
that looks right there.
That's perfect.
I think this will be perfect.
This'll be great.
Can we see -- Yeah, that's good.
Your cheeks -- Yeah.
That's so cute.
This up here. That's perfect.
Okay, just -- Yeah, that's good.
-Look, I really want to just --
I don't know.
-I think the
teleprompter's broken.
Can we fix it back to what...
Yeah, now these
are the real lines. Read this.
[ Lullaby playing ]
-I weally weally want my mommy
to take me to see "Bwack Adam."
-No, that's perfect.
That is perfect.
-I don't know.
-Yeah, no, that's great.
-Come on, man.
This can't be right.
-Trust me.
The kids are gonna love it.
And can you do that kid again,
this time with, like,
a New York accent maybe
for the kid.
-Wait. What?
-The kid -- the same kid --
the same kid,
but with a -- The same kid.
Have you ever worked with
anyone short?
-Yes, Kevin Hart, all the time,
but I don't --
-Okay, now, here you go.
Just pretend -- Just read it
with a New York accent,
and the kids will love this.
-A New York accent as a kid?
-Yeah. As a kid, yeah.
[ Lullaby playing ]
-[ New York accent ]
Hey, I'm walking over here
to go see "Bwack Adam."
Fugghetaboutit.
-Yeah, that's it.
That was perfect.
Yeah, that's great.
I don't want you
to be embarrassed.
Give me the hat. You're right.
Give me the hat.
Try this hat on.
Let's do some
quick tags real fast,
and we'll just get these out.
These are one-offs.
These are gonna go global, okay?
How about this one?
Pretend that you're in a
Charles Dickens novel.
Yeah.
-Like I'm hungry?
-Like a street -- Yeah.
Yeah, like a street urchin,
you know?
Yeah, you haven't eaten
in probably a year or so. Yeah.
-Okay. Wow. Okay.
[ Horse hooves clacking ]
Please, sir. Please.
I don't want gruel.
I want to see "Black Adam."
-That's very good.
No, that's good. That will work.
Yeah, can we get this in?
-It needs work.
What is -- Come on.
-Try one like Dracula.
This is perfect,
'cause it's almost --
It's October. It's close.
You know, you've got to be the
Halloween, wah-ah-ah.
Yeah, like that type of thing.
-Wah-ha-ha!
[ Organ playing ]
I vant you to see "Black Adam."
Ha ha! October 21st."
I don't know.
-That's perfect.
Now, look --
Yes, that will work.
We're getting -- I think we
got -- Let's do one more, okay?
This time,
I want you to do, like,
almost like a Southern --
like a Southern --
like a Southern little girl,
maybe.
That would be...
-I don't understand.
-No, yeah.
Like a "Oh! Oh, my. Oh, my.
Oh, my. Oh, my."
-Like a Southern belle?
-A Southern little girl,
like, "Oh, my."
-Like a Southern little girl?
-I don't know. Yeah, yeah.
"Oh, my." Like, "Oh, gosh."
-[ Southern accent ] Oh, golly,
I sure do love --
-Yes, yes.
-Are you sure, man?
-Yes, yes, yes!
-[ Southern accent ] Oh, golly,
I sure do love
sitting under this peach tree
and having my meemaw
buy me tickets to go see
"Black Adam."
Oh, my.
-That is perfect. That's great.
That is perfect.
I'm getting -- Wait.
I'm getting word from the booth.
I'm so sorry.
I forgot to press record.
Let's take it again
from the top.
-What?! Come on, dude!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪